- What we're looking
at is a printing plate
from a World War II German operation
known as Operation Bernhard,
in which the German Army attempted
to counterfeit British currency
to try to destroy the British economy.
My name is Dr. Vince Houghton,
and I'm the historian and curator
of the International Spy
Museum here in Washington, D.C.
The Spy Museum exists
to educate the public
about how important
intelligence work has been
throughout our history.
The economy was the
strength of Great Britain
during the Second World War.
But if you could strangle that,
if you could destroy that foundation,
then you could bring the
British nation to its knees.
The idea was to flood
Britain with fake currency,
so that no one could trust
the British economic system.
It evolved later on to
a way to launder money
and to create fake money
to pay German spies.
So this plate represents
an extraordinary moment
in the Second World War.
We think of the war as bombers and tanks,
and the blitzkrieg across Europe.
But really, Germany was
thinking in different ways.
This case is about economic espionage,
about economic warfare.
You can look at it and realize
how complicated this was.
The British had installed
multiple security features.
They had serial numbers that
were very well regulated.
They had watermarks on the bills,
not to mention the fact
that the paper used
was very specific to British currency.
When you touch it, it feels right.
It feels like money is supposed to.
Actually, it took a long time
for the Germans to figure out.
So this £10 note is indicative
of how good these guys actually were
at counterfeiting this money.
At the beginning of 1945,
the Germans realized
the war was coming to a close
and they were going to lose.
The operation gathered up
all the printing plates
and all the fake currency
and decided to get rid of the evidence,
and threw it into a deep lake in Austria,
hopefully to never be seen again.
But we did find it.
What's extraordinary
about this artifact is
it's the only surviving plate
from Operation Bernhard.
We can actually make out the carving
and the artisanship and
how much craftsmanship
went into creating this object.
The reason I like this artifact so much
is that it really bring across the idea
that you can win wars in different ways.
This is indicative of
intelligence agencies
and governments trying to find the edge-
the way to defeat their
enemy any way possible.